rescue efforts are still underway in
surf side florida despite
a brief pause due to heavy rain high
winds and lightning from elsa
crews recovered eight more bodies from
the rubble yesterday
bringing the confirmed death toll to 36
at least 100 people are still
unaccounted for
manuel pajorquez is in surf side manny
officials
allowed members of the media to get a
closer look at the rubble
what struck you what stood out what did
you see
well jerica good morning we were allowed
to get closer to the side of the
building that was demolished on sunday
night
away from where the search for victims
is still taking place you can see
there's a lot of traffic right here
but we were able to see from the other
side of the bus on that street level
is the massive scale of this disaster
and the work
at hand for crews on the pile
sifting through a mountain of concrete
steel and debris
rescue crews continue the
round-the-clock search for survivors
but good news is in short supply the key
things we're looking for
all throughout in regards to voice space
livable spaces
you know we're not coming across that
still leaders insist they are not giving
up hope
it's hard to imagine this was once a 12
story condo building but it's the little
things
like that cushion right there that was
once part of a sofa or patio furniture
that reminds you of the lives lost a few
blocks away
four of those lost were laid to rest the
guada family
marcus anna and their 10 and
four-year-old daughters lucia and emma
friends say they were an incredibly
close and loving family
symbolically the two young sisters were
placed together
in the same white casket adorned with
ribbons
with the cause of the champlain tower
south collapse still unknown
serve side mayor charles burkett says
there are significant concerns
about the virtually identical sister
building champlain towers north
and in nearby sunny isles nearly 60
commercial and residential buildings
built before 1982 are set for inspection
that era had a lot of people who were
laundering money who were looking to
bury cash somewhere
and took a lot of shortcuts florida
state senator jason pizzo
represents surfside in sunny isles he's
pressing for legislation to make
building records more transparent and
available
and wants greater oversight of condo
boards and associations
which make decisions about building
repairs we live in the ultimate you know
buy and flip
region very little legacy interest in
miami and that's the biggest concern
it takes a mass tragedy because this
allows people
that would otherwise look the other way
to say no you can't
you can't escape this one you're not
getting away with this one
and something has to change
of course the cause of the champlain
tower south collapse
remains under investigation and although
several lawsuits are working their way
through the court system right now it is
unclear which parties if any
may bear responsibility jamie people
watching that piece very carefully manny
thank you